If the listener is wondering, hmm, I wonder if his wife is going to let him do this when they have a two-week-year-old. That is crying a lot. The answer is no. My hobby is going to be, I would say very sadly, but not sadly, because we're starting a family. And that, to be honest, is much more exciting. Like, odds are I would never have this hobby if I didn't make it to the age of 35 with no children, no dependence, and no serious responsibilities. There was an Instagram reel. One time that I saw, like, a few years ago, that said, if you're born in 1990, you're doing one of the following three things.
如果听众在想，嗯，不知道他老婆会不会让他们在有个两周大的、经常哭闹的婴儿时还让他这么做？答案是不会。我的爱好将是——我可以说非常遗憾，但其实也不遗憾，因为我们要组建家庭了。说实话，这要兴奋得多。就像，如果我没有活到35岁、没有孩子、没有家属、也没有严重的责任，我大概永远也不会有这个爱好。曾有一个Instagram短视频，几年前我看到的，上面说，如果你是1990年出生的，你正在做以下三件事中的一件。
One, getting married, two, starting a family, or three, running a marathon. Welcome to ADSP the podcast, episode 295 recorded on July 13, 2006. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we chat about city strides, graph algorithms, GPT 5.6, soul, and more. It's exciting times. Okay, okay, all right, so first thing, so listen, I, despite me being very AI forward, I'm still like an old man. And by that, I mean, like, there's some places where I'm using AI everywhere,
第一，结婚；第二，组建家庭；第三，跑马拉松。欢迎收听ADSP播客，第295期，录制于2006年7月13日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起聊聊City Strides、图算法、GPT 5.6 soul等内容。这是一个令人兴奋的时代。好的，好的，好吧，所以第一件事，听着，我，尽管我对人工智能非常推崇，但我依然像个老头子。我这么说是因为，有些地方我到处都在使用人工智能，
but there's a lot of other places where I feel like I see other people on the internet using AI to solve parts of their life in ways that I just, I've just been too stubborn or haven't been able to get the momentum to, like, adopt. Like, I haven't been using, like, an AI personal assistant for anything. Like, I don't have it, like, reading my emails or writing my emails. I don't have it like managing my to-do list, etc. And I mostly have just been using it for coding. And in kind of like a dumb way, like I don't have, I use all these like persistent,
但还有很多其他地方，我觉得我看到互联网上的其他人用人工智能来解决他们生活中的问题，而我只是——我太顽固了，或者一直没能提起动力去采纳。比如，我没有在任何事情上使用过人工智能个人助理。比如，我没有让它帮我阅读邮件或写邮件。我没有让它帮我管理待办事项列表等等。我基本上只把人工智能用于编写代码。而且是以一种有点笨拙的方式，比如我不用，我用所有这些持久化的——
I use all these ephemeral agents that like run in VMs. I don't like build up like a deep skill library. I don't build up a deep memory library. Like I'm, I feel like I'm using it in a very different way than other people. But I kind of, I've kind of like recognized that more and more of my time is being, or AI has accelerated so much of parts of my, you know, work. You know, like, accelerated my output in so many places that the places where I used to not think about wasting time, I'm now like, crap.
我用所有这些在虚拟机中运行的短暂代理（ephemeral agents）。我没有建立起深厚的技能库。我没有建立起深厚的记忆库。我觉得我使用它的方式和别人非常不同。但我渐渐地意识到，我的越来越多的时间正被——或者说人工智能加速了我工作中很大一部分。你知道的，比如，在很多地方加速了我的产出，以至于在以前我从不介意浪费时间的领域，我现在会想：糟糕。
Like, I just spent three hours, like, going through my email inbox and think about all the stuff I could have done in that time. And the thing that I started using last week was computer use and, like, browser use. And the reason I started using it is kind of. kind of interesting. So if you go to chat GPT or ClaudeCode or Codex, like the CLI, or you just go to chat GPT, and you tell it like, hey, go get me prices for this specific flight. Like, I want to fly from New York to Toronto on this date. Go get me prices for it. What I want it to do is I want it to like go to Google flights or Expedia or any of the tools that like I use to go and price out
比如，我刚刚花了一个小时去整理收件箱，然后回想我本可以在这段时间里做多少事。我上周开始使用的是“计算机操作”（computer use）和浏览器操作。我开始使用它的原因其实挺有意思的。所以，如果你去ChatGPT、ClaudeCode、Codex（比如CLI），或者直接去ChatGPT，告诉它，嘿，去帮我查一下这趟特定航班的价格。比如，我想在某个日期从纽约飞往多伦多。去帮我查一下价格。我希望它做的是，我希望它去Google Flights、Expedia，或者任何我用来查询航班价格的工具——
flights or like maybe I'll ask it for hotels and again I have like you know some sort of tools I want it to go and use and what I've found is it just doesn't have access to a lot of stuff and I think what happens is if you ask it to go to like flights.google.com or like on some sites some sites either need a login to get useful information. Another good example of this is if you ask it to look up a tweet. Sometimes if somebody vague posts something, instead of me trying to figure out what they're like alluding to in their post, I'll just, I'll just like send a link of it to chat GPT. But I don't actually send a link anymore, because if I give it a link to Twitter, it can't actually see the tweet in a lot of cases. I'll send it a screenshot instead. But with the flights thing, if it goes to
或者也许我会向它询问酒店，同样，我也有一些工具希望它去使用，而我发现的是，它根本无法访问很多内容。我觉得发生的情况是，如果你让它去诸如flights.google.com之类的网站，或者某些网站，有些网站需要登录才能获取有用的信息。另一个很好的例子是，如果你让它查找一条推文。有时如果有人发了语焉不详的帖子，与其让我去猜他们在帖子里暗示什么，我不如直接把链接发给ChatGPT。但我现在其实不发链接了，因为如果我给它一个推特链接，很多情况下它实际上看不到那条推文。我会改发一张截图。但在航班这件事上，如果它去到
flights.com, it can't actually pull up data there. And I don't know if it's because it needs a login or if it's that when it goes to that site, that's like when an agent or any sort of automated system goes to a website, there's some protocol where it asks the website like, hey, you know, I'm a robot, can I come look at your site, this like robots.txtee thing. And there's a bunch of sites that are like, no, go away. So it's either that or it's the login thing. And so there's this set of tasks that I wanted to be able to do that it just can't do because it doesn't have, it doesn't have the access that it needs. And then sometimes there's like a website I wanted to use where like it doesn't have an
flights.com，它实际上无法在那里调取数据。我不知道是因为它需要登录，还是因为当它访问那个网站时——就像当代理或任何自动化系统访问网站时，会有某种协议，它会问网站说，嘿，你知道的，我是个机器人，我能来看看你的网站吗，也就是这个robots.txt文件。有很多网站会说：不，走开。所以要么是这个原因，要么是登录的问题。因此，有一类我想让它能够完成的任务，它就是做不到，因为它没有所需的访问权限。然后有时会有我想用的网站，它没有
API, you know, like it's something where it's not easy to interact with. And that's specifically why I want the agent to deal with it because like it would require a million clicks on this annoying website for me to go and do something. Like, oh, I want to go apply for some visa for some country or something where, you know, websites for visas are notoriously like awful to interact with. And so there's this thing called like computer use where basically instead of like going through an API or even just like looking at the HTML of the website, it interacts with your browser or some app on your computer just like the same way you would with like point and click. You know, like it controls the mouse. And it really saddens me that this is like, this has to be one of the most inefficient ways for an AI to interact with something.
API，你知道的，就是那种交互起来不太方便的网站。这就是为什么我专门想让代理来处理它，因为如果让我去完成某件事，需要在那个烦人的网站上点上一百万次。比如，哦，我想去为一个国家申请某种签证之类的，你知道的，签证网站出了名的难以交互。所以这就有一个叫做“computer use”的东西，基本上它不是通过API或者仅仅查看网站的HTML，而是像你通过点击一样，与你的浏览器或电脑上的某个应用进行交互。你知道的，它控制鼠标。这真的让我很难过，因为这似乎是人工智能与事物交互的最无效率的方式之一。
Like, it goes to the website, and I literally watch it going through and, like, entering stuff into form fields and, like, clicking buttons and whatnot. And it's just got to be so, like, wildly inefficient. But it does kind of get the job done. Like, I had it automate a lot of the, like, flight tracking and, like, flight search and award, like, redemption tracking stuff that I do. And I was, like, pretty happy with it. It was funny, though, to see, like, the AI complaining about how slow the website was, like, sort of validated for me, like, sort of validated for me, like, it took it like five hours to create like 20 flights worth of tracking on this one website. And I'm like, crap, did I used to spend five hours doing this myself?
比如，它访问网站，而我眼睁睁看着它浏览并把东西输入表单字段、点击按钮等等。这肯定极其、极其低效。但它确实能把事情办妥。比如，我让它自动化处理了许多我做的航班追踪、航班搜索以及里程兑换追踪的事情。我对此相当满意。不过挺逗的是，看到人工智能抱怨网站有多慢，这某种程度上证实了——某种程度上证实了我的想法，它在这个网站上创建大约20个航班的追踪花了我大约五个小时。然后我想：糟糕，我以前真的花五个小时自己做这事吗？
Anyways, I don't know if you started using any of this, but for me at least it's been, it's been very powerful. I haven't done any computer use stuff, but. Like, I'll give you an, I'll give you an example. I bet you that there is something related to running that you do that involves using some website that has a not great UI that doesn't have like an easy API to access, that you probably interact with semi-regularly, that you could probably automate with computer use.
不管怎样，我不知道你是否开始使用这些东西了，但对我而言，它一直非常强大。我没有做过任何computer use的事情，但是……我可以给你一个例子。我敢打赌，肯定有某种与跑步相关的事情是你做的，它涉及使用某个UI不太好、没有容易访问的API的网站，你可能定期会和它交互，你大概可以用computer use把它自动化。
Well, it's funny that you guessed that, because I was trying to figure out how to articulate what I've been doing with my running. But the problem is that, like, I have this, like, multi-headed hydra of different stuff. That, I mean, we've talked about this, actually. I'm pretty sure we have. Let me check on the website, ADESP,
好吧，你猜得真准，因为我一直在琢磨该怎么表达我一直在跑步方面做的事情。但问题是，我这儿有各种各样乱七八糟的事情，简直像个多头蛇。这——我的意思是，我们其实讨论过这个。我确信我们讨论过。让我去网站上查查看，ADESP，
An episode that had the word, did it have City Street? Yeah, it had episode 149, 2000, 23, September 29th, Citestrides.com, graph algorithms, and more. And we never actually talked about in-depth how to solve it. I just, like, threw the problem out there. And I wonder if you go to the GitHub discussion. I know that we got a couple comments. And remind me at the end of this 30-minute discussion
有一集标题里有这个词，里面有City Street吗？对，那是第149集，2000年，2023年9月29日，Citestrides.com、图算法以及更多内容。我们其实从未深入探讨过如何解决它。我只是把这个问题抛出来了。我想如果你去GitHub讨论区看看。我知道我们收到了一些评论。在这30分钟讨论的最后提醒我，
to talk about GitHub discussion things again. Anyway, so we, I have many. mentioned this very tricky problem that I tried to solve at one point. So, I mean, I can explain it a bit again, but let's take a step back. For those of you that recall, one of my biggest things that I spend time on is a website called city strides.com. It ranks or it tracks, you upload your Strava or you connect your Garmin or Strava, and it tracks all the roots, the GPS files that you run, and then it figures out how many streets that you've completed. And the tricky thing about this is you don't actually need to run the full length of the street.
再谈谈GitHub讨论区的事情。总之，我们，我有很多。提到了这个非常棘手的问题，我曾经试图解决过。所以，我的意思是，我可以再稍微解释一下，但让我们后退一步。对于你们当中还记得的人来说，我花时间最多的事情之一是一个叫citystrides.com的网站。它会进行排名或追踪，你上传Strava或者连接你的Garmin或Strava，它会追踪你跑过的所有路线、GPS文件，然后计算出你完成了多少条街道。而这其中棘手的地方在于，你其实不需要跑完全部长度的街道。
You just need to run over the nodes that define the street. So some streets only have two nodes, a start and an end because they're very short and they're straight. Other streets are very, very long and they're windy, so you need a bunch more nodes. And so my hobby is going and doing this. In 2023, I don't know, you'd have to go back and listen to that episode. I was probably in the top 100, top, you know, a couple hundred. You do know this because you actually referred to it when we were walking in Venice and I was collecting the nodes.
你只需要跑过定义这条街道的节点即可。所以有些街道只有两个节点，一个起点和一个终点，因为它们非常短而且是直的。其他街道非常非常长而且弯弯曲曲，所以你需要更多的节点。而我的爱好就是去完成这些。在2023年，我不知道，你们得回去听那一集。我可能在前100名、前几百名。你确实知道这一点，因为当我们走在威尼斯街头、我在收集节点时，你实际上提到过它。
But I have become like obsessed. Like it to say, I can't remember who said it once that I don't have passions. I have obsessions. But like if I was, you know, focused on city strides and collecting nodes back in June, I am now like a full-blown, like addict. I have gone and written two, well, technically I wrote one Python graph algorithm to generate like optimal roots and I've become like an open street map. I wouldn't say expert, but there's like an equivalent, an open source equivalent to We're going to talk about that Python script in a little bit.
但我已经变得像着迷了一样。就像——我不记得是谁曾经说过我没有激情，我只有痴迷。但如果我，你知道的，在6月份时专注于city strides和收集节点，我现在就是一个地地道道的上瘾者。我已经去写了两个——严格来说我写了一个Python图算法来生成最佳路线，并且我变成了一个OpenStreetMap的——我不会说我是专家，但有一个类似于开源的……我们一会儿再聊那个Python脚本。
Yeah. Well, I wrote it initially in Python and then I was like, this is too slow. I need to speed it up. Let's convert it to, you know, Rust, why not? And I just got ChatGTP to do it. And it worked amazing, Matt. Nice. And anyways, my point is, I've become.
嗯。好吧，我最初是用Python写的，然后我想：这太慢了，我得提速。把它转换成，你知道的，Rust，为什么不呢？我只是让ChatGPT帮我做了。效果好得惊人，老兄。太棒了。不管怎样，我的意思是，我已经变得……
I'm very much obsessed, and I'm going to be, I said this on my other podcast as well, that I'm currently ranked, you know, I think at the time on my other podcast, I was ranked 116th. I'm now ranked 114th. I will be ranked number one in my lifetime, probably within the next few years. I'm now ranked 13th in the world, soon to be number one in like a decade. And I spend like, especially right now, because it's, two months before Shima's due date, I'm trying to complete the entirety of Toronto before she gives
我非常痴迷，而且我将——我在我的另一个播客上也说过，我目前的排名，你知道的，我想当时在我的另一个播客上，我排在第116位。我现在排在第114位。我有生之年一定会排到第一名，可能就在未来几年内。我现在世界排名第13位，大约十年内很快就会成为第一名。我花了很多时间——尤其是现在，因为离希玛（Shima）的预产期还有两个月，我正试图在她生产前跑完整条多伦多街道。
birth. Because once my son is here, right now the hobby consists of me. It used to be just going for a run, you know, running some weird route and then getting some streets. But I have completed every single street within like a seven kilometer radius of where I live. And so now what I have to do is hop in the car, you know, drive anywhere from 15 to 20 minutes, sometimes more if traffic's bad on like a weekend. And then I go park the car in some parking lot of a grocery store. I start my run from there and my run and then drive back home. And if the listener is wondering, hmm, I wonder if his wife is going to let him do this when
因为一旦我儿子出生，现在这个爱好包括我。过去只是去跑步，你知道的，跑一些奇怪的路线，然后完成一些街道。但我已经完成了离我住处大约七公里半径内的每一条单行道。所以现在我不得不跳上车，你知道的，开车15到20分钟，如果周末交通不好有时会更久。然后我把车停在某个杂货店的停车场。我从那里开始跑步，跑完后再开车回家。如果听众在想，嗯，不知道他老婆会不会让他们在有一个
they have a two-week-year-old that is crying a lot. The answer is no. My hobby is going to be, I would say very sadly, but not sadly, because we're starting a family and that, to be honest, is much more exciting. Like, odds are I would never have this hobby if I didn't make it to the age of 35 with no children, no dependence, and no serious responsibilities. There was an Instagram real one time that I saw like a few years ago that said, if you're born in 1990, you're doing one of the following three things. One, getting married, two, starting a family, or three, running a marathon. And the exact
两周大的、经常哭闹的婴儿时还这样做？答案是不会。我的爱好将是——我可以说非常遗憾，但其实也不遗憾，因为我们要组建家庭了，老实说，这要兴奋得多。就像，如果我没有活到35岁、没有孩子、没有家属、也没有严重的责任，我大概永远也不会有这个爱好。曾有一个Instagram短视频，几年前我看到的，上面说，如果你是1990年出生的，你正在做以下三件事中的一件：第一，结婚；第二，组建家庭；第三，跑马拉松。而这个精确的
hobby that takes a lot of time, you know, it doesn't actually need to be a marathon, but I thought it like, it nailed me so hard because at the time I wasn't getting married or having kids, I was spending a lot of time running though. And anyways, the point being, is that I'm trying to finish Toronto, which has like 10,318 streets, I think, and I'm at about 8.5,000. And one of the websites I actually have, it tracks the top 50 people and like... Has anybody else completed Toronto? Yes, three other people. In fact, very tragically, there was a man that was raising money for, I believe, a music foundation. And he was, I'm not sure if he was in his 70s or 80s, but he had cancer. And he was doing it to, like, raise awareness,
需要大量时间的爱好，你知道的，其实不一定非得是马拉松，但我当时觉得它太戳中我了，因为当时我既没结婚也没孩子，不过我确实花了很多时间跑步。总之，重点是，我正试图完成多伦多，它大约有10,318条街道，我想我已经完成了大约8,500条。我实际拥有的网站之一，它追踪了前50名的人，还有……有没有其他人完成了多伦多？有，另外三个人。事实上，非常悲惨的是，有一个人为我深信是一个音乐基金会筹款的人。他当时，我不确定他是70多岁还是80多岁，但他患有癌症。他这样做是为了提高人们的意识，
which really puts like me doing it to shame because I'm not trying to raise awareness for anything and he I think just passed away in the last month and on a happy, happy note he completed Toronto just like a month or two before he passed away and anyway so he is one of three people Carlo, let me actually just get his name
这真的让我觉得自己做这件事相形见绌，因为我并不是在为什么事情提高意识，而他我想刚刚在上个月去世了。不过说个高兴点、高兴点的事，他在去世前大约一个月或两个月刚刚完成了多伦多。不管怎样，他是三个人中的一个，卡洛（Carlo），让我把他的名字找出来，
because we should shout him out and I'll leave a link if you want to go and leave a donation because he had a page for it but actually let me share my screen because I'm probably gonna but yeah so this is City Strides and the most, the number one, or I guess the second person in Toronto right now, because everyone's in a while. How do they define Toronto here? I see a blue line around. Yeah. So it is like the, it's, it's the
因为我们应该向他致敬，如果你们想去留下一笔捐款，我会留下一个链接，因为他有一个专属页面。不过其实，让我分享一下我的屏幕，因为我可能要——对，所以这就是City Strides，目前多伦多排名第一，或者说第二的人，因为每隔一段时间……他们在这里是怎么定义多伦多的？我看到周围有一条蓝色的线。对。所以它就像是，它是
municipality boundary defined by like different, you know, latitude and longitudes or whatever that are specified, I'm sure, in some legal document. And so yeah, but actually the first city strider, so actually I lied. Four people have finished it. And for some reason, one of them is private. Carlo de Lorenzi was the individual that just passed. away recently and was raising money. The other two are named Matthew and Richard. I'm good friends with Brian who's ranked in seventh. I just passed him. I'm now ranked sixth. And probably in a week or two, I'll pass Steve, who's ranked in fifth. But you have more total streets than all of these people. Interesting. Yeah, yeah. So I'm definitely like the number one Canadian city strider in
由不同的，你知道的，在某个法律文件中指定的经纬度或诸如此类定义出来的市政边界。所以，是的，但实际上第一名City Strider——其实我撒谎了。有四个人完成了。出于某种原因，其中一个是私密的。卡洛·德·洛伦齐（Carlo de Lorenzi）就是最近刚刚去世并一直在筹款的那个人。另外两个人叫马修（Matthew）和理查德（Richard）。我和排在第七位的布莱恩（Brian）是好朋友。我刚刚超过了他。我现在的排名是第六。可能在一两周内，我就会超过排在第五位的斯蒂夫（Steve）。但你的街道总数比所有这些人都要多。有趣。对，对。所以我绝对是世界上排名第一的加拿大City Strider。
the world. But that's because like I spend a lot of time. Like it's basically every time, if I'm not training for like a race. And even if I am training for a race, like I ran a marathon when I was in Ireland, it did not go well. Arguably a part of that is that even when I'm trying to do like a workout, which involves like one kilometer repeats five times, I go in city stride while I do that. So like I'm in the middle of trying to run like a kilometer really fast and I've got my phone in my hand and I'm looking, I've got to take a left hand turn here. It's probably I should try and do one at a time. Either go ahead. So I notice some streets here that look more like highways. Is there, like, do they exclude from city streets, streets that are, like, not safe for a pedestrian to go on?
但那是因为我花了很多时间。就像基本上每次，如果我没有在为某场比赛进行训练。即使我在为比赛训练——比如我在爱尔兰时跑过一场马拉松，结果很不顺利。可以说部分原因在于，甚至当我想进行某种训练时，也就是包括五次一公里的重复跑，我一边跑一边还在用City Strides。所以就像我正试图以极快的速度跑完一公里，手里拿着手机在看，我得在这里左转。我可能应该一次只做一件事。或者你先说。所以我注意到这里有些街道看起来更像高速公路。这里面，他们会把对行人不安全的街道从城市街道中排除吗？
Yes. I won't go into the details, but yeah, highways and, like, high traffic, unsafe roads are always excluded. That being said, like, when I was in... Like, I noticed this, like, Kingston Road on the far right there that... Oh, Kingston Road is not a highway, so this is a road. Okay, that's, you just haven't gotten over there. Yeah, yeah, that's the, like, part of Scarborough. I'm, like, 75% done Scarborough right now, which is a...
是的。我不会细说，但是的，高速公路以及车流量大、不安全的道路总是被排除在外的。话虽如此，就像我在……比如我注意到最右边的那个金斯顿路（Kingston Road）……哦，金斯顿路不是高速公路，这是一条路。好吧，那是你还没跑到那儿。对，对，那是士嘉堡（Scarborough）的一部分。我现在大概完成了士嘉堡的75%，这是一个……
embedded like region within Toronto. So technically Toronto is composed of old Toronto, which is downtown, York, East York, North York, Atobico and Scarborough. And so I've done everything but Atobico and Scarborough. And so if you click on Kingston Road, because you can see here that it actually says like there's a Kingston Road for Scarborough and there's a Kingston road for Toronto. And the one in Toronto has more nodes because it's a super set. And if you click on this, it'll show you if I get rid of this. All of the dark purple ones are the nodes that I run and the red ones aren't. And it says that I'm 38.22% done this road.
多伦多内部的一个嵌入式区域。所以严格来说，多伦多由老多伦多（即市中心）、约克（York）、东约克（East York）、北约克（North York）、怡陶碧谷（Etobicoke）和士嘉堡组成。我除了怡陶碧谷和士嘉堡之外都跑完了。所以如果你点击金斯顿路，因为你可以从这里看到它实际上显示士嘉堡有一条金斯顿路，多伦多也有一条金斯顿路。多伦多那条有更多的节点，因为它是一个超集。如果你点击这个，它会显示——如果我去掉这个。所有深紫色的都是我跑过的节点，红色的则没有。它说这条路我已经完成了38.22%。
And a very important trick that comes into the algorithm that I'll show in a little bit is that you only need to complete 90% of the nodes in order for it to be considered done. And Kingston is a special road in that it's 33 kilometers long. You're never running that all at once. And so it just happens slowly over time. but most streets are anywhere from, you know, two nodes to 40 nodes. And so if you have a 40 node street and one of the nodes is like a couple hundred meters away because it's just at the end of a long straight part of that road,
而算法中非常重要的一点——我一会儿会展示——是你只需要完成90%的节点就可以被认为完成了。金斯顿路很特殊，它长达33公里。你不可能一次性把它跑完。所以它只是随着时间慢慢完成。但大多数街道的节点数从两个到40个不等。所以如果你有一条40个节点的街道，其中一个节点在几百米外，因为它正好在那条路长长直道的最末端，
you can actually skip that, you know, 40th node and you'll still get completion for it. Hang on, hang on. That's cheating. You have to get all of the actual nodes in Toronto before the baby. So that is what city stride purists say. And there's a mode called hardcore mode that you can click that requires 100%. I am not hardcore. I am just trying to climb this leaderboard as fast as possible,
你其实可以跳过那个第40个节点，你依然可以算作完成这条街道。等一下，等一下。那是作弊。在宝宝出生之前，你必须拿下多伦多的所有实际节点。这就是City Strides纯粹主义者们的说法。有一个叫硬核模式（hardcore mode）的模式，你可以点选它，要求达到100%。我不是硬核玩家。我只是想尽快爬上这个排行榜，
which means that I'm not trying to run the full length of these streets, which was covered in episode 149. So yeah, I'm trying to finish Toronto before the baby comes. And I did actually have like a route mapping if we go to. And so actually, well, I can show you. What do I want to show you first? This is the website that shows like, you know, the top 50. So there I am.
这意味着我并不打算跑完全部长度的街道，这在第149集里讨论过。所以，是的，我正试图在宝宝出生前完成多伦多。我其实确实做了一个路线规划，如果我们去……实际上，我可以向你们展示。我首先想展示什么？这是显示前50名的网站。所以这就是我。
And it's got a separate tab that shows like the completion of the sub-minicipality. within Toronto and then just some other random cities that I run in often. You've completed New York? North York, not New York. Oh, okay. Okay, all right, I understand. Yeah, North York. It's like the northern part of Toronto.
它有一个单独的标签页，显示多伦多各次行政区的完成情况，以及我经常跑步的其他一些随机城市。你完成了纽约（New York）？是北约克（North York），不是纽约。哦，好吧。好吧，我明白了。对，北约克。它就像是多伦多的北部地区。
And you can see here, like, I even have this little projection. So if I run five times a week, you know, one of the estimates say I'll finish September 3rd, the other one says October 1st. And you can see that like in the last little bit, I've really started to go crazy. Like when I got back from, if I zoom in a little bit here, when I got back from Ireland, And basically I've been running every single day, city striding. And if I kick it up to, you know, six runs a week, then it says September 3rd versus September 18th.
你可以从这里看到，我甚至还有这个小小的预测。所以如果我一周跑五次，你知道的，其中一个估计说我将在9月3日完成，另一个说10月1日。你可以看到，在过去的一小段时间里，我真的开始疯狂了。就像我从——如果我在这里稍微放大一点，当我从爱尔兰回来时，基本上我每天都在跑步，进行City Striding。如果我把频率提高到一周跑六次，那么它显示的就是9月3日对阵9月18日。
The due date is September 15th. So, you know, it depends, though. Are we going to make it? Maybe, maybe not. Stay tuned. And the thing that I was doing over the weekend was trying to basically create a better version of the, so if we go to city strides, except that I don't have an old version of this because I did get rid of it.
预产期是9月15日。所以，你知道，这得看情况。我们能赶上吗？也许能，也许不能。请拭目以待。我周末在做的事情基本上是试图创建一个更好版本的——所以如果我们去City Strides，不过我没有这个的旧版本，因为我把它删掉了。
Anyways, it was a very bad route planner, but it wouldn't like start and end at the same spot. And it just had a bunch of issues. And anyway, so I just basically over the weekend was talking to AI and saying, you know, these are my criteria. There's two different routes you want, right? If you're visiting, you know, Italy, Rome and you're only there for a couple days, you don't want to complete a whole section.
不管怎样，那是一个非常糟糕的路线规划器，它不会在同一个地点开始和结束。它有一堆问题。总之，我整个周末基本上都在和人工智能对话，并说，这些是我的标准。你想要两种不同的路线，对吧？如果你正在访问意大利罗马，而且你只呆几天，你不会想要完成整个区域。
You just want the maximum number of streets possible, which means targeting the shortest streets, skipping the long streets, et cetera. But if you're trying to complete 100% of the city, you want like a dense, you know, and one of the biggest problems with these automatic root generations is like stranded streets. You don't want to create a route that strands one or two streets that are going to require running an extra two or three kilometers because you left them behind. Anyways, I won't go into all the details because the viewer or the listener can't see this.
你只想要尽可能多的街道数量，这意味着以最短的街道为目标，跳过长街道等等。但如果你试图完成100%的城市，你就会想要一条密集的路线。而且这些自动路线生成器最大的问题之一就是“滞留街道”（stranded streets）。你不想创建一条路线，让一两条街道被遗留下来，而这需要你多跑两三公里去补上它们，因为你把它们落下了。总之，我就不细讲所有细节了，因为观众或听众看不到这个。
But now, like, the idea is. That stranded street thing is some sort of, there's some sort of grass. property. Yeah, like, and that's the thing is as I was having conversations over the weekend, like, I basically just kept on verbally explaining, like, heuristics it needed to add where, like, you know, you'll see here when I've zoomed into a road called Wonderland Drive. And, like, at one point, it was generating this route that not only would run the full length of Wonderland Drive once, but it would double back.
但现在，这个想法是……那个滞留街道的问题某种程度上是某种图论属性。对，就是这样。当我整个周末都在进行对话时，我基本上一直在口头解释它需要添加的启发式算法（heuristics），比如，你会看到这里，当我放大到一条叫做仙境大道（Wonderland Drive）的道路时。而且，有一段时间，它生成的路线不仅会完整跑完一次仙境大道，还会折返。
And the point being is, there's no nodes in between basically, like, the start and the end of the street. And so, like, not only do you not want to run. it twice. You don't even want to run it once. You want to just get over the start and the end and like add that to your route. And so I would explain this heuristic and it would be like, oh yeah, that makes sense. That makes sense. And then there's a bunch of other heuristics like the, you know, minimizing the stranded streets because it completely defeats the purpose if you isolate two or three streets. Like, basically like that's a non-starter. Like it's a thing
关键在于，基本上在这条街的起点和终点之间没有节点。所以，不仅你不想跑它两次，你甚至连一次都不想跑。你只想经过起点和终点，然后把这加入你的路线中。所以我就会解释这个启发式算法，它就会说：哦，对，这说得通。这说得通。然后还有一堆其他的启发式算法，比如最小化滞留街道，因为如果你孤立了两三条街道，那就完全违背了初衷。基本上，这是不可接受的。这是它必须做对的事情。
it has to get right. Anyway, so now basically these show you all like the nodes that I have to, you know, collect so far. I choose the distance. I go build closed loop and it just starts doing it. And that's the thing. I don't fully understand what it's doing right now. And you can see whenever there's yellow nodes, those are ones that'll be completed basically by hitting 90% of the nodes. And it's not perfect yet. You can see here that it kind of missed this cul-de-sac. Like if you're running by a cul-de-sac that has no other, like that's the definition of a cul-de-sac. It just has one entrance. It should definitely get this. So it's not perfect yet, but honestly, it's pretty good. And so anyways, this is a long-winded response to your, like,
总之，现在基本上这些展示了所有我目前必须收集的节点。我选择距离。我点击构建闭环，它就开始运行了。就是这样。我并不完全理解它现在在做什么。你可以看到，每当出现黄色节点时，那些基本上就是通过命中90%的节点就能完成的节点。它还不够完美。你可以看到这里它有点漏掉了这个死胡同（cul-de-sac）。如果你跑过一个没有其他出口的死胡同——那就是死胡同的定义，它只有一个入口。它绝对应该拿到这个。所以它还不够完美，但老实说，相当不错。总之，这是对你提出的问题的一个冗长的回答……
there's probably something you spend a lot of time. Every single day, basically, I go for a run, I get back for my run, I run a bunch of scripts that, like, update my websites and rankings and whatnot. And then I'll spend, you know, 20 to 30 minutes basically designing my run for the next day based on, you know, a start and end location and just basically manually creating, like on the City Strides website, they have a button for creating a route. and so you can just go here manually and start like once you see the nodes you just manually click around and this will give you a basically a GPS file some people loaded into their garbans but I basically
基本上每一天，我去跑步，跑步回来后，我运行一堆脚本来更新我的网站和排名等等。然后我会花20到30分钟，根据起点和终点的位置，基本上为第二天设计我的跑步路线，并且直接在City Strides网站上手动创建——他们有一个用于创建路线的按钮。所以你可以直接来这里手动开始，一旦你看到节点，你就可以在周围手动点击，这会给你生成一个GPS文件。有些人把它加载到他们的Garmin手表里，但我基本上只是在跑步时把网站开在手机上。现在我要给自己每天节省30分钟。老实说，我确信我可以把它做到这种程度：它不仅能为我节省时间，而且比我凭肉眼粗略估计制作的任何手动路线都要好上25%，因为我无法不断地点击街道去检查这条街有多少节点、我当前的完成进度是多少等等。但这不涉及任何computer use。这依然是……有趣的是，我一开始使用的是Cursor，因为当我在构建这样的软件且不进行自动研究时，
just like have the website open on my phone while I'm running around and now I'm going to save myself like 30 minutes a day and to be honest I'm pretty sure I can get this to the point that it is not just saving me time but like 25% better than any manual route that I can just kind of eyeball right because I can't constantly be clicking on streets checking how many nodes does this have, like what's my current completion, yada, yada, yada. But like this doesn't involve any computer use. This is still, and the funny thing is, is I was using cursor at first because I still, when I'm building like software like this and I'm not doing auto research,
我仍然更喜欢Cursor，但我发现——我们现在可以谈论5.6 soul了吧？对，对，我们可以谈论。是的，所以在我看来，5.6 soul比Opus 4.8好太多了。基本上我让Opus 4.8和5.6 soul都在处理这个问题，而Opus 4.8总是犯一些非常低级的错误。我不能说是低级的错误。它做得还行。但我看到GPT 5.6 soul通过自身的工作和迭代所展现出来的洞察力，它会说：啊，实际上，你知道的，我真的应该采用这种启发式算法。它基于几条路线建立了一些测试引擎。并且它确保了每次它添加另一个启发式算法时，它并没有在它之前设置好的其他启发式算法上出现倒退。它做了一些很复杂的事情。我在某个时刻差不多放弃了Opus 4.8。
I still prefer cursor, but I found, and we're allowed to talk about 5.6 soul now, right? Yeah, yeah, we can, yeah. Yeah, so 5.6 soul is so much better than Opus 4.8 in my opinion. like I basically had both Opus 4.8 and 5.6 soul like working on this problem and Opus 4.8 just kept on like making really silly. I shouldn't say silly mistakes. It was doing okay. But the insights that I saw GPT 5.6 soul making just by working and iterating it on itself, it'd be like, ah, actually, you know, really I should like do this kind of heuristic. And it set up some like test engine like based on a couple routes. And it made sure that like every single time it added a another heuristic. It wasn't regressing on some other heuristic that it had set up earlier. Like, it did some sophisticated stuff. And I kind of just gave up on Opus 4.8 at some point.
而且，我还要求它们两个都提供一个可视化。Opus 4.8做出来的那个是一个Plotly刷新、超级超级慢的东西。我甚至不知道GPT 5.6这个是从哪来的。它使用的是Leaflet。我想它们用的是一样的东西。但从设计的角度来看，这个明显要好得多。我让它更改了颜色之类的。不管怎样，我一直在喋喋不休地废话。我不说了。所以我们做的是同一件事，只是我这边不使用computer use。所以访问所有节点的这个问题，一次性访问且不走回头路，
And also, too, like, I just asked for a visualization from both of them. And the one that Opus 4.8 came up with was like a plotly refreshing, super, super slow thing. I don't even know what this is from GPT 5.6. It's using leaflet. Like, I think they were using the same stuff. But this one was just so much better from like a design point of view. I asked it to change the colors and stuff. But anyways, I've been kind of rambling nonstop. I will stop talking. So we're doing the same thing, just not computer use on my part. So this problem of like visiting all the nodes, you know, once without backtracking.
我其实觉得，好吧，回到我第二次上大学并获得数学学位的那段日子，我记得有一种东西叫做哈密顿路径（Hamiltonian path），也就是你访问每个节点一次，或者也许是一条遍历——对，就像遍历每个顶点一次，我想。不过我在想，这其实不完全是你的问题，因为我觉得对于你的问题来说，你不太在乎——访问同一个节点两次其实是没问题的。你更在乎的是边（edges）。你不想多次走同一条边，因为那是浪费时间碰巧你又回到了某个节点，那没问题。
I actually think, well, so for, okay, going back to my days in college the second time around and, you know, getting a math degree, I recall there being something called a Hamiltonian. path, which is where you visit every node once, or maybe it's a path that goes over, yeah, like over every vertex once, I think. I wonder, though, whether that's, I think that's not exactly your problem, because I think that your problem, you care less about, like, visiting the same node twice is fine. You care more about the edges. You don't want to go down an edge multiple times, because that would be wasted time. Like if you, if you happen to come back to a node again, like, that's fine.
但是，你甚至可以在这里看到，在这条路上，Mountland Drive，它已经识别出，去往这剩下的五个节点的间距——它其实不需要这些节点，因为它已经有足够多的节点了。在某个时候，它总是完成这个并形成一个环。但经过关于它所需的启发式算法的多次对话后，它终于弄清楚了，在某些特定时间，做180度转弯并进行回溯，才是你想做的最佳选择，
But, you can, you can even see here that, like, on this road, mountland drive, like, it is identified that, like, the gap to these remaining five nodes, which it doesn't need because it's got enough nodes. Like, like, at one point, it was always completing this and, like, making a loop. But it's made, like, after having enough conversations about it, about the heuristic that it needed, it's finally figured out that at certain times, doing 180 degree turn and backtracking, is the optimal thing you want to do,
但你始终需要评估：现在是时候了吗？就像，甚至在这里，严格来说，如果我这样做，我绝不会在这里回溯，因为权衡之下，通过在这里回溯你只能省下一小段跑步距离，
but you always need to be assessing, like, is this the time? And like, even over here, technically, if I was doing this, I would never, like, backtrack here because the trade-off, like, you're only saving a little bit of running by backtracking here,
但因为它已经做了一些最优计算，上面说：实际上，我应该在这里做180度转弯并回溯，而不是完成这个环，因为它能为我节省距离，哪怕只是很小的一段距离，
but because it's just like, it's done some optimal calculation where it says, actually, I should do 180-degree turn here and backtrack instead of, like, completing this loop, because it is going to save me, even if it's a small amount of distance,
那也是节省，对吧？但是，这并不是一件简单的事情，尤其当你考虑到你要查看多少节点时。好吧，我打断你了。我想我知道哈密顿路径问题是一个NP问题，对，哈密顿路径问题，虽然汉密尔顿（Hamilton）附近有一个多伦多。所以也许你在汉密尔顿遇到了哈密顿路径问题。但我相信哈密顿路径问题是一个NP完全问题。
it's still a saving, right? But, like, this is not like a, a simple thing to like program, especially when you think about how many nodes you're looking at. And yeah, anyways, I interrupt you. I think that I know that the Hamilton Path problem is an NP, yeah, the Hamiltonian path problem, although there is a Hamilton near Toronto. So maybe you have a Hamiltonian path problem in Hamilton. But I believe the Hamiltonian path problem is an NP complete problem.
而且我认为它和旅行商问题属于同一类问题。但我查过了。访问图的所有边恰好一次被称为欧拉路径（Eulerian path）或欧拉回路（Eulerian circuit）。我认为这个问题有一种表述叫做中国——我觉得根据这个，它有时也被称为中国邮递员问题（Chinese postman problem）。我在想，当你周末在研究它时，你有没有遇到过这个或任何背后的图论知识？我的意思是，我自己没有做任何研究。这只是和模型对话的结果，
And I think it's in the same family of problems as like traveling salesmen. But I looked it up. Visiting all the edges of a graph exactly once is called an Eulerian path or an Eulerian circuit. And I think there's a formulation of this problem called the China. I think it's sometimes also known as the Chinese postman problem according to this. And I wonder, when you were looking at it over the weekend, did you come across that or any of the graph theory behind this? I mean, I did no research on my own. It's just been talking with the models.
而且在任何时候从……我们不是曾经讨论过柯尼斯堡七桥问题吗？对，对，那可能……让我们实际查一下……如果我们回到这里……当我访问欧拉路径的维基百科页面时，它提到的第一件事就是它们最初是由欧拉
and at no points from... Didn't we once talk about the seven bridges of Coensburg problem? Yeah, yeah, that might have... Let's actually check the... So if we go back here... When I go to the Eulerian Path Wikipedia page, one of the first things it mentions is that they were... They were first discussed by Euler
在解决著名的柯尼斯堡七桥问题时讨论的。是的，我想说的是，图算法和七桥问题，我不确定这是否是因为City Strides而提出的。所以City Strides没有提到。我想你当时只是在欧洲旅游，偶然翻到了一本算法书。在那本算法书里，它谈到了图算法。所以毫无疑问，这些确实出现过。
while solving the famous Seven Bridges of Coinsberg problem. Yeah, I was going to say, the graph algorithms and seven bridges, I'm not sure if this came up because of cities. So City Stride doesn't mention. I think you were just traveling in Europe and you had come across some algorithm book. And in the algorithm book, it was talking about graph algorithms. So definitely, like, these have come up.
但就像在研究这些模型的痕迹时，诚实地说，它们并没有告诉你它们在想的所有事情。这并不是因为这个而出现的，因为我认为这有本质上的不同。这不像是访问所有东西一次。完全可以访问一个节点两次。如果那是最佳做法，完全可以回溯。真正的目标是，你只是想在不遗漏任何道路的情况下完成一个区域，在不需要跑过所有东西、每一个节点的前提下以最优的方式做到这一点。
But like in studying the traces or studying, in reading the traces of these models, admittedly they're not telling you everything they're thinking about. It hasn't come up because I think this is like substantially different. This isn't like visiting everything once. Like it's totally fine to visit a node twice. It's totally fine to backtrack if that's the optimal thing. Like the real goal here is you're just trying to like complete a section without leaving any roads behind, doing it optimally in terms of like you don't need to run over everything, every single node.
就像——老实说，内置的一种启发式算法肯定是：任何时候当你穿过一条路，并且自从你跑过的上一个节点以来的距离在增加，这是一个不好的迹象。因为这意味着，你可能在不必要地跑一段你根本不需要跑的路线。有时这肯定会发生。但是，你知道，当它——当它在那个位置时，听众看不到，但是它决定在这里回溯。然后，为了到达它还没见过的下一个最近节点，它需要跑一段没有节点的距离。是的。所以如果我没记错的话，或者说并不是所有的图都有欧拉路径。
And like you don't like really a kind of, I'm sure a heuristic that's built in is that any time you're traversing a road and the distance since the last node that you've run over is like increasing, that's a bad sign. because it means that, like, you're probably unnecessarily running, like, a path that you don't need to run. And sometimes it definitely is going to happen. But, like, you know, like, when it's, when it's over here, which the listener can't see. But, like, it's decided it wants to backtrack here. And then, you know, in order to get to the next closest node that it hasn't seen, it needs to run a bit of distance where there are no nodes. Yeah. So if I recall correctly, or not all graphs have an all therein path.
并且我相信，图里所有的顶点是否属于一个单一连通分量或强连通分量之间存在着某种关系。可能的情况是，只有那些所有顶点都属于一个连通分量的图才具有欧拉路径，我的意思是那种只需访问每个顶点一次的路径。所以，是的，你是对的。你试图解决的问题并不是——比如定义欧拉路径，因为它可能根本不存在。它更像是某种形式的——你知道的，找到最接近欧拉路径的东西，且带有最少量的……它大概是某种形式的最短路径问题。
and I believe that there's a relationship between whether the graph, like whether all of the vertices and the graph belong to a single connected component or slash strongly connected component. I think that it might be the case that it's only graphs in which all the vertices belong to a sync to like to one connected component have an o'larian path, by which I mean a path where you only have to visit. every vertex once. And so, yeah, like, you're right. The problem that you're trying to solve is not, like, define the Eulerian path because it may not exist. It's, like, some form of it of, like, you know, find the closest thing to the Eulerian path with, like, the least amount of, it's some form of, like, shortest path problem, probably.
而且我相信，图中的所有顶点是否属于单个连通分量（或强连通分量），这两者之间存在某种联系。我认为，可能只有所有顶点都属于同一个连通分量的图才具有欧拉路径——我的意思是，那种只需访问每个顶点一次的路径。所以，是的，你说得对。你试图解决的问题不是去寻找欧拉路径，因为它可能根本不存在。它其实是某种形式的……你知道的，寻找最接近欧拉路径的东西，并且具有最少数量的……这大概是某种形式的最短路径问题。
It's some, it's certainly, it's some class of optimization problem for sure. Microphone in use. All right. They both seem to be picking this up. what do you call a part of a graph that is represents like a street so a street has nodes and those nodes have edges and then on a map you've got a bunch of streets so what do you call like a single street within a map that's made up of a bunch of streets because that's basically what we we want it's called a path an order of sequence of nodes connected by edges representing one street through the larger road network path path the graph theory term polyline so yeah Basically, when you have a graph that consists of paths, we want an algorithm. Actually, so let's see what Chachy. I'm on Medium right now on just like the web thing.
这肯定是一种优化问题。麦克风正在使用中。好的。它们两个好像都在收音。你把图的一部分叫什么，它代表一条街道，所以一条街道有节点，这些节点有边，然后在地图上你有一堆街道，所以你把地图中由一堆街道组成的单条街道叫什么，因为这基本上就是我们想要的，它被称为路径，由通过边连接的节点组成的顺序序列，代表穿过更大道路网络的单条街道，路径，图论术语，折线，所以，基本上，当你有一个由路径组成的图时，我们想要一个算法。事实上，让我们看看 Chachy 的情况。我正在 Medium 上看网页版的内容。
So is there a name for the type of algorithm that solves wanting to complete a certain percentage of every path within a graph? And it doesn't matter how many times you visit edges and nodes, but you want that path to be as short as possible. What do you think it's going to say? I think it's going to say one of your Eulerian or Hamiltonian things? Actually, I think that... Chinese postman problem. It sounds like a variant of the Chinese pose. Why is he Chinese?
那么，有没有一种算法专门用来解决想要完成图中每条路径的一定百分比的需求？而且访问边和节点的次数并不重要，但你希望该路径尽可能短。你觉得它会怎么说？我猜它会说你的欧拉或哈密顿问题之一？其实，我觉得……中国邮递员问题。听起来像是中国邮递员问题的变体。为什么他是中国人的？
So the Eulerian Path problem is specifically wants to not visit a vertex more than once, which I don't think you actually care about because what you care about, like, if you have to, if you would probably prefer to visit, sorry, not vertex, I meant edge. You would prefer to repeat a short street multiple times. if it was shorter than, you know, having to go on a really long street.
所以欧拉路径问题专门要求不要多次访问同一个顶点，我觉得你其实并不关心这个，因为你关心的是，如果你必须的话，如果你可能更喜欢访问，抱歉，不是顶点，我是说边。你宁愿多次重复一条短街道，如果它比，你知道的，不得不走一条很长的街道更短的话。
Like, you care about, you care about a shortest, like, distance. So the number of times that you repeat something maybe isn't as important. Yeah, I mean, in general, when you see some street being double-backed on or, like, triple-backed-on, which is something that, like, I've never, I don't think ever in a manually created street, am I, like, tripling back on a street? doubling a lot of the times whenever I'm spinning around and changing direction like that happens multiple times a run but so in general you're trying to avoid that when it's not necessary for the optimal or shortest path but yeah in general it's like a good rule of thumb like if you find yourself constantly retracing your steps when it's not down like a corridor or a cul-de-sac like that's cause for concern so the connected component things I think is just a property of whether all of the nodes in the graph are reachable from each other, which makes sense. If some of the nodes are not reachable from other nodes,
就像，你关心的是最短距离。所以你重复某事的次数可能没那么重要。是的，我的意思是，总的来说，当你看到某条街道被重复走过两遍或三遍时——这在我手动创建的街道里好像从来没有发生过，我怎么会三倍地走一条街呢？在跑步过程中，当我转身并像那样改变方向时，很多时候会重复很多次，但总的来说，当你不需要为了达到最优或最短路径而这样做时，你是在试图避免这种情况。不过是的，总的来说，这是一个很好的经验法则：如果你发现自己不断地重复足迹，而这并不是在走走廊或死胡同，那就是一个值得关注的问题。所以连通分量的事情，我认为这只是一种属性，关于图中的所有节点是否都可以从彼此到达，这说得通。如果某些节点无法从其他节点到达，
then obviously no such path where you visit all of them uniquely once exists. But I think there's also some other property. I think there's some properties related to how many, like the degree of each node, like how many points into and out of it there are. like if you have one node that only has one edge out of it, then, and it's like in the middle of your graph, then it's going to be very hard to uniquely visit. Like you can't uniquely visit that node without taking that edge twice. Right.
那么显然不存在你可以以唯一方式访问所有节点的此类路径。但我认为还有其他一些属性。我认为有些属性与数量有关，比如每个节点的度数，也就是有多少条边指向它以及从它引出多少条边。比如，如果你有一个节点，它只有一条引出的边，而且它在你的图的中间，那么要以唯一的方式访问它将是非常困难的。就像你不能在不把那条边走两遍的情况下唯一地访问那个节点一样。对吧。
Yeah. I mean, the interesting thing here, too, is that, like, you don't actually care about any edge. At the end of the day, all you care about is nodes. The edges are incidental. Right. And, yeah, when I, when I... You care about... So the type of graph that you have here is actually, it's a form of what I believe is called a weighted graph. And it's weighted because the cost of each edge is not the same, right?
是的。我的意思是，这里有趣的事情还在于，你其实并不关心任何边。归根结底，你在乎的只有节点。边只是次要的。对吧。而且，是的，当我，当我……你在乎的是……所以你这里拥有的图的类型实际上是我认为被称为加权图的一种形式。它是加权的，因为每条边的成本是不一样的，对吧？
You know, some edges might be really long and some might be really short. Yeah. Like, it's a, it's an undirected, you know, weighted, weighted graph. Interesting. Yeah, I mean, it's probably, like, I suspect strongly this is one of those sorts of problems that, like, one of these classes of optimization problems that's like in the NP complete family is very computationally intensive to solve. But you know what? GPU is very good at craft problems. Have you like looked at coopt? You should you probably coopt probably has like algorithms for this. Maybe. Actually,
你知道，有些边可能真的很长，有些可能真的很短。是的。就像，它是一个无向的、你知道的，加权加权图。有趣。是的，我的意思是，这可能，我强烈怀疑这是那种优化问题，属于 NP 完全问题系列，计算密集度很高，很难解决。但你知道吗？GPU 非常擅长图问题。你有没有看过 coopt？你可能应该看一下，coopt 可能有针对这个的算法。也许吧。其实，
should we just ask, should we ask? Can you explain roughly your route planning? Isn't this just traveling salesman? Well, so yeah, yeah, I mean at one point I asked, chat chabit, and it mentioned that the quota traveling salesman problem is finding the shortest route that visits at least a required number or percentage of nodes. But the thing is, and I'm sure there are like graph theory experts out there that work for Google and on Google Maps like rooting software, that they have a whole set of vocabulary. But like this is a very special graph in that it's not just like traveling salesman with a bunch of nodes and like some random edges. Because you only need 90%. Well, no, it's not that I, yes, I, I, yes, I, I,
我们是不是应该直接问，应该问问吗？你能大致解释一下你的路线规划吗？这不就是旅行商问题吗？嗯，所以，是的，是的，我的意思是，有一次我问了 chat chabit，它提到配额旅行商问题是找到访问图中至少所需数量或百分比的节点的捷径。但问题是，我确信有谷歌的图论专家在谷歌地图等路线软件上工作，他们有一整套词汇。但这是一个非常特殊的图，它不仅仅像带有许多节点和一些随机边的旅行商问题。因为你只需要 90%。嗯，不，不是我，是的，我，我，是的，我，我，
only need 90%, but it's, I only need 90% of each path, which is typically falls into a set of types of roads. Like there's a cul-de-sac where there's only one entrance and exit, and then there's a corridor, like a street, which has like a start and an end. And like, so when you hit a cul-de-sac, like, you know you have to do it. That sounds like a call. So I remember from school that there was this idea of like graph coloring. And I wonder whether that's, maybe applicable here because you essentially you have different classes of nodes or maybe the nodes are in different subgraphs is the way to think about it, right? Because like you have some property that you want to be true for each, like each street you kind of want to model. And I recall when we talked about this last time that you you talked about like modeling each street separately.
只需要 90%，但我只需要每条路径的 90%，这通常属于某几类道路。就像有只有唯一一个出入口的死胡同，然后有走廊，比如一条有起点和终点的街道。所以当你遇到死胡同，你知道你必须走它。这听起来像是一个呼叫。我记得在学校里有图论着色这个概念。我想这也许可以应用在这里，因为你本质上有不同类别的节点，或者也许节点在不同的子图中，这是思考的方式，对吧？因为你有一些属性希望对每个属性都成立，比如你想模拟的每一条街。我记得我们上次谈论这个时，你谈到了单独模拟每一条街。
But like each street is like its own graph or you want you want some property to hold across each street that you hit some some required. number of nodes. Yeah, I mean, I don't really know. Like, because that's the thing is, if each street is really its own graph, like, it's actually quite a simple graph, right? It's just like a straight line. Or like, even if it's not straight, it's curved, but for all tens and purposes, you've just got, like, a linked list, you know, very rarely do streets, like, fork and then, like, rejoin or I guess if it's a cul-de-sac, it might look like a lasso. But, like, the graphs, like the paths that form up the larger graph are actually quite simple. The complicated thing is that, like, if you can complete a path by just completing four other
但每一条街就像它自己的图，或者你希望某种属性在你遇到的每一条街上都成立，达到某个所需的节点数量。是的，我的意思是，我真的不知道。因为这就是问题所在，如果每条街真的是它自己的图，其实它是一个非常简单的图，对吧？它就像一条直线。或者即使它不是直的，它是弯曲的，但在所有意图和目的上，你只有，比如，一个链表，你知道的，街道很少会分叉然后重新合并，或者我想如果它是死胡同，它可能看起来像一个套索。但是，那些图，就像构成更大图的路径其实很简单。复杂的事情在于，如果你可以通过只完成其他四条刚好蜿蜒穿过图的路径来完成一条路径，如果你认为你只有一个矩阵，比如五条街乘五条街，所以你有一大道到五大道和第一街到第五街，它们都彼此垂直，就像街道和大道一样，最好的办法是忽略街道或大道，只做之字形的来回走动。然后，从技术上讲，你在大道的长度上奔跑而忽略了街道。但当你跑完大道的时候，顺便你也跑完了街道。所以，从图论的角度来看，你如何表示这一点呢？
paths that happen to, like, wind through, like, if you think of you just have a matrix, like, you know, five streets by five streets, so you've got first through fifth avenue and first through fifth street and they all are perpendicular to each other, like the, streets and the avenues, the best thing to do is to ignore either the streets or the avenues and just do like a zigzag back and forth. And then, like, you're technically running the length of the avenues and ignoring the streets. But by the time you've completed running the avenues, incidentally, you've completed the streets. So, like, how do you represent that, like, from a graph theory point of view?
因为如果你只看每条路径而不考虑它所属的更大图，你知道，你最终会完全做一些不像蛇形图案的事情。你知道，这就是问题所在，你想要看到整个图，或者至少是当前关注的子集。无论如何，我让 Codex 解释它一直在做什么。它说，大致上，它是一个贪婪的图搜索优化器。所以它实际上并没有做什么花哨的事情。它从所有相关的开源地图路网、人行道、路径、桥梁中构建一个可走图。对于每条街，它计算需要多少额外的节点才能达到 90% 的阈值，同时考虑到已经完成的节点。从你选择的位置开始，它反复给附近的街道评分。
Because if you only look at each path without respect to, like, the larger graph that it's a part of, you know, it's, you're going to completely do something that's not, like, doing the snake pattern. You know, like, it's, that's the thing is, like, you want to see the whole graph, or at least, like, a subsection that you're focused on at the moment. And so anyways, I asked Codex to explain what it's been doing. And he said, roughly, it's a greedy graph search optimizer. So it's not actually doing anything fancy. It builds a walkable graph from all the relevant open street map, road, sidewalks, path, bridges. And for every street, it calculates how many additional nodes are needed to reach the 90% threshold, accounting for nodes that have already been completed. Starting from your selected location, it repeatedly scores nearby streets.
有两种不同的算法。最大化寻找短且便宜的街道。而完全完成度则偏爱部分开放的街道和紧凑的群组，同时惩罚孤立的剩余部分和受困的口袋。最短路径搜索将这些目标连接起来，对于重复使用相同的道路走廊、长距离行进但没有城市大步节点、没有产生新进展的边，以及冒着留下不足以回家的距离风险的选择，会有额外的成本。这是目前这个算法最薄弱的部分，基本上当它达到大约 80%
There's two different algorithms. Maximum looks for short, inexpensive streets. and the total completion favors partially open streets and compact groups while penalizing isolated leftovers and stranded pockets. Shortest path searches connect those targets with extra costs for reusing the same road corridor, traveling long distances without city stride nodes, edges that produce no new progress, and choices that risk leaving insufficient distance to return home. That's the weakest part of this algorithm right now, that basically once it hits like the 80%
标记时，它就会找到回家的最短路径。即使有这个明显的缺陷，它仍然是一个相当不错的结果，也许我们待会儿可以讨论一下，因为……这里有个问题，图论和最优解是什么？你在这里处理的是什么图论问题？然后，计算上最合理的方法是什么？你刚才描述的代理商的事情，你知道的，可能属于最合理的类别。因为也许解决这个问题的最优方式是一些荒谬的计算密集型东西，你知道的，比如某种估计某些 NP 难问题解的方法。
mark, it just like finds the shortest path home. which it's still pretty good result, even with that, like, glaring flaw, which maybe we can talk about in a sec because... There's the question of what, like, what is the graph theory and the optimal... What is the graph theory problem that you're handling here? And then, like, what is the computationally most reasonable way to approach this? and the thing that you're just that your agents describing here, you know, is probably in the class of things that are like most reasonable. Because like maybe the optimal way to solve this problem is like some ridiculously computationally intensive thing, you know, like some way to estimate some solution to some NP, you know, hard problem.
你不需要最优解，你需要一个相当不错的解，在你愿意为此花费的计算资源范围内，对吧？就像，假设，解这个问题的最优路径存在，但需要你在 GPU 集群上运行，比如，八天左右。那显然不是正确的答案。当我搜索时，它提到了
And you don't need, you don't need the option. solution, you need, like, a reasonably good solution, you know, within the bounds of how much compute you're willing to spend on this, right? Like, you wouldn't, let's say that, like, the, the way to solve this, like, to actually find the optimal route existed, but, like, required you to run on, like, you know, a cluster of GPUs for, like, you know, eight days or something. Like that would not would obviously not be the correct answer. When I'm searching, it's mentioning
我搜索的内容，我问的是我有一个包含许多带标签子图的图。我想要穿过每个子图 90% 的顶点的最短路径。这个问题叫什么？它说这就像带配额的广义旅行商路径问题，也被描述为
what I searched, what I asked was I have a graph consisting of many labeled subgraphs. I want the shortest path that goes through 90% of the vertices of each subgraph. What is this problem called? And it says it's like the quota constrained generalized traveling salesman path problem, also described as
带有每组配额的群组斯坦纳路径问题。我从未听说过广义旅行商问题。我不知道相对于旅行商问题这意味着什么，但也许“广义”部分只是因为它泛化了成本函数。广义旅行商。广义旅行商问题。广义旅行商问题，其中图的节点被划分为离散的子集或集群，
the group Steiner path problem with per group quotas. I've never heard of the generalized traveling salesman problem. I don't know what that means relative to the traveling salesman problem, but maybe it's the generalized part is just that it generalizes the cost function. Generalized traveling salesman. Generalized traveling salesman problem. Generalized traveling salesman problem where the graph's nodes are partitioned into discrete subsets or clusters,
目标是找到在返回起点之前恰好访问每个集群一个节点的尽可能短的路线。是的，所以它是某种类似于旅行商的问题。尽管你需要的具体表述听起来有点独特。是的，说实话，我觉得它现在拥有的贪婪算法已经达到了我所需的大约 90%。它只需要，实际上，现在这管用吗？如果我们选择，如果我们选择一些新的位置，所以让我们去，让我们一路去，一路去这里。
the objective is to find the shortest possible route that visits exactly one node from each cluster before returning to the start. Yeah, so it's something and some class of traveling salesman-like problem. Though the specific formulation that you need sounds like it's a little bit unique. Yeah, honestly, I feel like the greedy algorithm that it has now is like 90% of what I need. It just needs, like actually, does this work right now? So if we chose, if we choose some new location, so let's go, let's go all the way over, all the way over here.
而且实际上，我试过这个好几次了。所以，如果你要从这个角落开始，它显然有一个入口，它有两个入口。算法要做的是它会首先完成这个小三角形。但实际上我会做的是，你知道的，我会向北走，在那里做一堆事情，然后从南部完成，然后来到这里。但如果我现在做完全完成并且我这样做，（你知道的，看它是如何立即形成一个三角形来完成这里的这两条街的？这并不是最优的，对吧？
And so actually, I've tried this one a couple of times. So like, if you're going to start in this corner, it's clearly got like one entrance, it's got two entrances. What the algorithm's going to do is it's going to complete this little triangle first. But really what I would do is, you know, I would go north, do a bunch of stuff up here, and then finish from the southern part and then come up here. But if I go total completion right now and I do this, you know, see how it immediately formed a triangle to like complete these two streets here? Like this is not optimal, right?
因为它的贪婪部分是，好吧，让我完成离起点很近这两条街。但当我回来时，基本上我是在其中一条街上重复走，而我本可以完全避免这种情况的。而且，它在这里做了极其有害的事情，让这条罗奇山大道（Rouge Hills drive）保持开放，这意味着如果我要创建一个，另一条，（你知道的路线），它基本上必须加倍，它必须跑完整条长度（看起来有一两公里），然后折返回来，因为那边没有什么可以完成的，这就是为什么，如果我从这个角落开始，它应该能够，推理出，好吧，我想向北走，做一堆事情，然后从南方结束。
Like, because the greedy part of it is like, well, let me complete these two streets that are close to the starting point. But then by the time I get back, I'm basically like doubling up on one of these where I could have totally avoided that. And then also too, it does the incredibly harmful thing right here of leaving this Rouge Hills drive open, which means that like if I were to create a, Another, you know, route, it would basically have to double, it would have to run this whole length, which looks like a kilometer or two, and then double back because there's nothing over here to finish, which is why, like, if I'm starting in this corner, it should be able to, like, reason that, like, all right, I want to go north, do a bunch of stuff and then finish from the south.
但现在它只是，它只是贪婪的，对吧？所以如果我选择其他地方，比如没有被困在那个角落的地方，如果我们只选这里，我确信它会做得更好得多。看它也很有趣。是的，所以，你的算法不会回溯吗？它不会，不。嗯，我是说，我不应该这么说。我觉得它不会，因为
But right now it's just, it's just greedy, right? So if I choose some other place that's, like, not boxed into that corner, like, if we just choose here, I'm sure it'll do a lot better. It's very fun to watch, too. Yeah, so the, you're. algorithm doesn't do backtracking? It does not, no. Well, I mean, I shouldn't say. I don't think it does, because
显然当我们看它动画时，它不会暂停、思考和绘制任何东西。它只是总是在向前移动。是的，所以，就像你刚才描述的三角形问题一样，我觉得如果你没有某种前瞻或回溯，你是抓不到那个的。是的，我没有，这就是问题所在，对吧？
clearly when we watch it animate, it doesn't like pause, think, and on draw anything. It just is always moving forward. Yeah, so, so like the triangle problem you just described, like, I think you can't catch that without either some form of look ahead or backtracking. Yeah, I don't, and that's the problem, right?
就像，你要前瞻多远，因为实际上当我在跑步结束时，这需要是 16 公里之后的事，如果你要前瞻那么远等等，并且做某种类似于蒙特卡洛树搜索的事情，你知道，这是一个非常棘手的事情。我也想过，做某种人类辅助的版本，基本上你选择一个起点，然后你选择一系列点，你知道的，在那些点你有点知道你想让算法去哪个方向，然后你希望它自己填满其余部分，这理想情况下会阻止它这样做，尽管如果它在做贪婪的事情，我不知道。我正在看的文献，它谈论了很多关于这个想法，像这个群组斯坦纳路径或带配额的广义旅行商问题，那就是，那里的目标是拥有访问每个集群中至少一个节点的最短路径。这个想法是你会，比如，假设你想连接一个计算机网络，对吧？就像你想把所有不同的子网连接在一起一样。把所有这些不同的、现有的网络连接在一起的最短方法是什么，类似这样的事情。
It's like, how far are you going to look ahead because really it needs to be like 16 kilometers later when I'm finishing the run, which if you're going to look that far ahead and whatnot and do like some kind of equivalent of like Monte Carlo tree searching like it's you know it's a very tricky thing to I've thought about too of like doing some kind of human assisted version where basically like you choose a starting point and then you choose like like a series of points you know where you kind of you kind of know the
所以这说得通。听起来你所需要的可能不是一个，我确信人们以前考虑过这个问题，但这并不是文献中广泛知道的事情，至少如果是的话，代理可能会想出它。是的，我的意思是，如果你想想大多数现实世界的路线问题，它是 A 点到 B 点，对吧？它不是在优化尝试完成。或者其实，我不知道。也许它是某种，虽然有多少，我刚才在想，如果你是一辆冰淇淋车呢？你想在最短的距离内在合适的时间访问所有的公园之类的。但我正要说有多少冰淇淋
direction you want the algorithm to go and then you want it to just fill the rest in and that would ideally prevent it from, although it's still, if it's doing the greedy thing, I don't know. The literature that I'm looking at, like, it's talking a lot about the idea, like, this like group Steiner path or the quota generalized traveling salesman problem, that is, the goal there is to have the shortest path that visits at least one node in every cluster. And the idea is like you would, like, let's say that you wanted to like connect a computer network, right? Like you want to have all the different, you know, subnets connected together. Like what's the shortest way to connect all these different, you know, existing networks together, something like that.
卡车企业在优化路线？我确信他们只是去几个公园然后就收工了。是的。我能想象到的这个算法的一个应用可能是，我本来想说，比如你有一个现有公交车站的网络，但你觉得你有一个，比如在纽约，有些公交路线有太多的公交车站。因此，提出一个只覆盖这些公交车站 80% 的更好路线将是最佳选择。但那个问题不会有你那样的聚类方面，即你有多个不同的路线需要优化。是的。
So that makes sense. It sounds like the thing that you need may not be like a, I'm sure people have thought about this problem before, but it's not like a widely, you know. known thing in the literature, at least if it was, the agent probably would have come up with it. Yeah, I mean, if you think of most real world rooting problems, it's point A to point B, right? It's not optimally trying to complete. Or actually, I don't know. Maybe it is some, although how many, I was just thinking, like, what if you're an ice cream truck? You want to hit, like, all the parks in the shortest distance at the right times or something. But I was about to say how many ice cream
如果人们知道完全是我们谈论的那种图算法，请随意。你本应该看 GitHub 讨论的，因为人们可能。哦，对，对，对。我是说，不是那一个。你是在告诉我你让我提醒你的事情吗？是的。是的，那是另一回事。但我的意思是，我们能，我们已经聊了一个小时了，而这原本又应该是 30 分钟。
truck businesses are optimizing the routes? I'm pretty sure they're just hitting a couple of parks and calling it a day. Yeah. It's probably like one application of this algorithm that I could imagine would be, well, I was going to say something like you have a network of existing bus stops, but you feel like you have, like in New York, like you have a, there's some bus routes where there's too many bus stops. And so it would be optimal to, you know, say like, okay, maybe let's, let's come up with a better route that only covers 80 of these bus stops. But that problem would not have the clustering aspect of yours where you have multiple different routes that you want to optimize across. Yeah.
我会把它剪成两半吗？我大概不会剪。我太懒了。是的。我得在几分钟后离开，因为我确实得去赶飞机。所以有个东西叫家庭旅行商问题，是一个 NP 难优化问题，其中的图节点被分为不同的类别（家庭）。目标是找到最短的可能路线，在返回原点之前访问每个家庭中特定预定义的节点数量。这听起来像你需要的。
If people know of graph algorithms that are like exactly what we're talking about, feel free to. You were supposed to look at the GitHub discussion because people may be. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. I mean, not of the one. Are you telling me the thing that I asked you to remind me of? Yeah. Yeah, that's something different. But I mean, we can, we've already been talking for like an hour now, and this was once again supposed to be 30 minutes.
家庭旅行商问题。也许吧。不过我刚才在想，我有一个，因为，正如我所说，这个算法最大的缺点之一是它有点只是达到 80% 或 90% 的标记然后就回家了。但我一直在想，有，我不知道它是不是 A* 变体或其他任何搜索，你从某些路线的起点和终点同时开始搜索，从 A 点到 B 点。然后，无论它们在什么时候相遇，无论你管它叫什么，那都是最短路径，而不是只从一个方向搜索，或者像那样，或者那可能不是一个不同的算法
Will I split it? I'm probably not going to split it. I'm too lazy. Yeah. I will have to leave in a few minutes because I do have to go get on a plane. So there's a thing called the family traveling salesman problem is an NP hard optimization problem where graph nodes are grouped into categories families. The goal is to find the shortest possible route that visits a specific predefined number of nodes within each family before we're turning to the origin. that sounds like what you need.
但这就像是为了更快找到它的一种优化——因为你从搜索的某种深度的某个点走得越长，或者 BFS，或者甚至是优先队列，越昂贵，也就是说你正在探索的地平线越大，你的算法运行得就越慢。但如果你从两个方向同时做，它会更快。我在想，你知道，如果你开始那样做，但从同一点开始，你有一些东西说，你知道，射出两个这样的东西，或者甚至四个或六个，并试着不让它们碰撞之类的。如果你从这里这样做，最初我的想法是它们大多彼此独立。但如果你，
The family traveling salesman problem. Maybe. I was just thinking, though, that I had a, because, like I said, one of the biggest faults of this algorithm is that it kind of just hits the 80% mark or 90% mark and goes home. But I was thinking, like, there are, I don't know if it's like an A-star variant or whatever search where you start searching from both the start and the end of some route from point A to point B. and then like whenever they meet each other, whatever you call it, that's the shortest path instead of just searching from one direction or like that or that's maybe not a different algorithm
如果你基本上让它们两个都开始，一个向左走，一个向右走，这行得通吗？我不知道，也许吧。是的，所以，是的，有各种各样的并行搜索技术。这个家庭旅行商问题听起来正是你所需要的确切定义。我正在看一些关于它的文献。这里有一些关于它的论文。当然它是 NP 难的。所以严格使用蛮力来解决它在计算上变得不可能。相反，研究人员和系统使用启发式方法和将问题分解为两个子问题的方法：宏观层面的规划访问哪些家庭，以及微观层面的计算最优节点顺序。生成最优或接近最优解的流行算法方法包括随机启发式、有偏
but it's like an optimization on finding it faster because like the longer you go from one point of some depth for a search or BFS or even if it's a priority queue like the more expensive like the bigger your horizon that you're exploring is so the slower your algorithm goes. But if you do it from both directions, it can be faster. And I was thinking, you know, if you started doing that, but from the same point and you had some kind of thing that said, you know, shoot two of these off or maybe even four or six and try to not have them collide or whatever. If you did that from here, initially my idea was that like they'd just be mostly independent of each other. But if you,
随机键遗传算法、进化算法和数学启发式，将精确求解器（如 C-Plex）与模拟退火或贪婪搜索过程相结合的混合方法。有趣。你应该跟，你应该跟 coopt 的人谈谈。也许吧。我大概已经把足够的个人资源花在解决这个问题上了，更不用说现在还要让除了你以外的其他人来思考这个了。不过，是的，也许我们需要给这个问题挂上一个 GPU。是的，无论如何，我们大概应该在这里结束。
if you basically had like both of them start one go left, one go right, would that work? I don't know, maybe. Yeah. So like, yeah, there's a variety of like parallel search techniques. This family traveling salesman problem sounds like it is the exact definition of what you need. I'm looking at some literature on it. Here's some papers on it. It's NPR, of course. So solving it strictly using brute force becomes computationally impossible. Instead, researchers and systems use heuristics and approaches breaking the problem into two sub-problems, a macro-level planning which families to visit, and a micro-level calculating the optimal node order. Popular algorithmic methods to generate optimal or near optimal solutions include randomized heuristics, biased
我得去，你知道的，去机场了。我要去波兰参加 Euro Python 和 Eurocypi。等等，等等。我们在看 GitHub 讨论吗？是的，我刚才提到最后一件事。所以是我错了。我欠布莱斯一个道歉。我说这是我们最无聊的剧集之一，
random key genetic algorithms, evolutionary algorithms, and math heuristics, hybrids combining exact solvers like C-Plex with simulated annealing or greedy search procedures. Interesting. You should talk to the, you should talk to the co-op people. Maybe. I probably have spent enough of my own resources on solving this problem, let alone now trying to get other people other than you now thinking about this. But yeah, maybe we need to hook a GPU up to this problem. Yeah. Anyways, we should probably wrap it here.
第 293 集有一个很棒的 GitHub 讨论，然后我们转到了这个。嗯，第 294 集有一个更好的 GitHub 讨论，他们说最有趣的部分是布莱斯，因为我滚动了你的声音好几次，人们很生气。民意已经表达了，他们想要更多这样的内容。
I got to get, you know, get to the airport. I got to go to Poland for Euro Python and Eurocypi. Wait, though, wait. Are we looking at the GitHub discussion? Yeah, last thing that I mentioned. So I was wrong. And I owe Bryce an apology. I said it was one of our most boring episodes ever
不管怎样，所以我错了，布莱斯。你是对的。更多，我不知道，你叫它什么？什么？用……解释的自动研究算法。有一个有趣的进展，有趣的进展是，我可能是错的，因为我正在和一些人聊天，
and that episode 293 had a great get-up discussion and then we switched to this. Well, episode 294 had an even better GitHub discussion and they were saying the most interesting parts were the ones were Bryce because I scrolled your voice a couple times and the people are upset. The people have spoken and they want more content like this.
或者我把它发到了 Vida 的内部 Slack 频道上，有人说不可能是 L2 银行冲突，因为 GPU 上的 L2 就像是基于物理地址而不是虚拟地址进行分块的。所以我得，我得再研究一下，确保，确保我真正理解了真正的问题是什么。嗯，那太棒了。所以我们将有一个重新审视 histocash 的节目，所有这些朋友都会在。
Anyway, so I was wrong, Bryce. You were right. More, I don't know, what do you call it? What? Auto research algorithms explained using... There is an interesting development, and the interesting development is, I may be wrong because I was chatting with some,
关于 histocash 的有趣事情，有趣的进展是，我一直在玩的最初版本是你在快速共享内存中有缓存。然后当缓存未命中时，你直接去全局内存。但我一直在玩更多对抗性输入。有一些对抗性输入会使性能直线下降，比如基本上你填满了缓存，然后其余的访问在全局内存中产生冲突。所以我现在尝试做的事情是，当溢出时，你溢出到全局内存中的私有化缓存。所以这整体上具有更平滑的性能。就像你放弃了获得的一些性能优势。就像你没有那么多，你知道的，你在某些输入上不是获得 4 倍的提升，你只获得 2 倍。
or I put this on an internal Slack channel at Vida, and somebody said it can't be L2 bank conflicts because the L2 on the GPU is, like, banked on based on physical addresses, not virtual addresses. So I got a, I got a, I got to look into it a little bit more to make sure, make sure I actually understand what the true problem is. Well, that's fantastic. So we will have a histocash revisited and all the folks.
但你有更少性能非常糟糕的输入。当我说性能糟糕时，我的意思是，你知道的，比现有算法慢 100 倍。它们非常像，你知道的，奇怪的对抗性情况。但我确实想尽量减少这些情况。现在我基本上添加了这个第二级缓存，有一些旋钮我可以摆弄。特别是其中一个旋钮是，我们应该，如果我们溢出到，比如，
The interesting thing, the interesting development with histocash is the original version that I've been playing around with was you have the cache in the, the fast shared memory. And then when you miss in the cache, you go directly to global memory. But I've been playing around with more like adversarial inputs. And there are some adversarial inputs where it really, really tanks performance, like where you basically, you fill up the cash and then the rest of the accesses are contended in global memory. So the thing I'm trying now is when you spill, you spill to a privatized cash in global memory. So this has smoother performance overall. Like you give up some performance wins that you get. Like you don't have as, you know, instead of getting 4x on some inputs, you only get 2x.
如果在缓存中未命中并且我们溢出到这个私有化直方图，我们应该在进入这个私有化直方图之前做类似合并的事情吗？然后如果你有这个私有化直方图，对于你如何最后合并所有局部直方图，有几种不同的选择。这里有一个问题：最后，你是将缓存合并到私有化直方图中，然后再将私有化直方图合并到全局直方图中？
But you have fewer inputs where you have really atrocious performance. And when I mean atrocious performance, I mean like, you know, 100x slower than the existing algorithm. And they are like pretty like, you know, odd adversarial cases. but I do want to try to minimize those as much as possible. And now that I've added in this basically this second level of caching, there's a couple knobs I can play around with. In particular, one of the knobs is, should we, if we're spilling into, like,
还是你将缓存直接合并到全局直方图中？所以这里有一整套新的选项需要我去尝试。所以我可能会在接下来的几周里探索这些。基本上，我想从算法中得到的是，拥有，你知道的，1.5 到 2 倍的，像，平均加速，同时尽可能少地出现性能回退。在少数情况下，它更像是 4 倍，但如果我能让它，比如，不出现回退，但是，比如，仍然有，像，一个非常大的，你知道的，到处都是 1.5 到 2 倍的加速。那就会让我很高兴，并且离可以发布更近一步。
if we miss in the cache and we're spilling into this privatized histogram, should we do something like combining before we go into this privatized histogram? And then if you have this privatized histogram, there's a couple different options for how you, combine all the local histograms at the end. And there's the question of, at the end, do you combine the cash into the privatized histogram and then the privatized histogram into the global histogram?
好的。那么，敬请期待，听众朋友们。我们会为您提供更新。我保证下次我会让布莱斯谈论所有的细节，然后我就会等待大家再次在 GitHub 讨论中欢呼雀跃。是的。
Or do you combine the cash directly into the global histogram? So there's a whole set of new options I need to try out here. So I'll probably be exploring those over the next couple of weeks. Basically, what I would like to get out of the algorithm is to to have the, you know, 1.5 to 2x, like, average speed up with as few regressions as possible. There's a couple cases where it's more like 4x, but if I can get it to, like, not have the regressions, but, like, still have, like, a pretty big, like, you know, 1.5 to 2x faster everywhere. That would then make me happy and be closer to being shipable.
我得放你走了。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 ADSP thepodcast.com 上，了解我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及可以留下想法、评论和问题的 GitHub 讨论链接。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。
All right. Well, stay tuned, listener. We will have updates for you. And I promise next time I'll let Bryce. talk about all the nitty-gritty, and then I shall just wait for the people to rejoice once again on GitHub discussions. Yeah.
高质量，低数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是洒满信息 sprinkles 的混沌。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可留下评论。
I got to let you go. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com, for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day.
我得让你走了。请务必查看播客应用中或访问 ADSP thepodcast.com 的本期节目shownotes，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及可供你留下想法、评论和问题的 GitHub 讨论区链接。感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。
Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
高质量，低产出。这是我们播客的标语。不对，这不是标语。我们的标语是“点缀着少许资讯的混乱”。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。